this was another busy newsweek and
three major events that occurred
demonstrate just how radical and how
dangerous the democrat party has become
now i know it sounds very hyperbolic but
bear with me
the evidence is mounting that joe
biden's party from elders to organizers
has adopted a by any means necessary
approach to winning in november
and the consequences for america will be
devastating in both the short
and long term first
if you thought that we could find
bipartisan agreement that
rioting should never be tolerated
think again in fact there seems to be an
implicit consensus among democrats today
that efforts should not be made to stop
federal buildings from arson
or even to stop attacks on law
enforcement at all
at the disgraceful inquisition of a.g
bill barr this week
democrat members of congress gave cover
to
actual criminals and treated barr
like he was the problem shame on you mr
barr
can i just say shame on you i think it's
a very important uh
non-lethal option for protesters
no foreign sir
sir i don't think that what was
happening immediately around the
courthouse was a peaceful protest
that's not my question mr barr oh that's
where that my question is do you think
as the chief
reclaiming my time reclaiming my time
every american who votes in november
should understand
that the democrat party will allow total
ma'am to go
unchecked and life's work destroyed
if perpetrators are anti-trump so if you
have the right motives they'll leave you
alone
now we learned that in new york alone at
the height
of its protests about a million dollars
in damage
was done just to the police cars that
were destroyed
and the damage to businesses was likely
in the tens
of millions the city's a total hell hole
now with skyrocketing crime
including murder rate going way up cuomo
and de blasio
are a duo of disaster but they don't
care
it's all about amassing more power and
for them
more control for them and hurting the
president's chances for re-election
now another indication that the
democrats have gone totally nutso
is their feigned hyperventilation
yesterday about trump's tweet about
mail-in voting
and this question of delaying the
election now
they all know he doesn't have the power
to do that nor was he even
saying that he'd really try to do that
for good reason the president
believes though that mail-in voting
would be a nightmare that would end up
delaying election results for weeks even
months
and that's what the democrats themselves
have repeatedly said
we are uh working to you know prepare
all of you and the public
with um you know to not ex to not get
the results immediately upon polls
closing on election night it very well
may take several more days the democrats
are
madly pushing mail-in voting for one
reason
they think it would help them beat trump
they know
and they don't even care that it can
lead to fraud and corruption
and there are already plenty examples of
this including most recently in new
jersey
but democrats are fine with millions of
untrackable and
sometimes untraceable mail-in ballots
floating around undermining the
integrity of our entire electoral system
causing confusion instability and even
violent unrest for days or weeks after
election day
for them it just ends up being another
insurance policy to help biden
thirdly it's obvious that the democrats
including biden want
america to shut down again with newer
and even
more draconian controls over your
movement
you can't get this country going again
unless you get
coveted under control we cannot expect
to reopen the economy safely if the
values experience is spreading unchecked
dr foster can you help us understand why
while europe has largely contained the
virus
when they shut down or locked down or
went to shelter in place
however you want to describe it they
really did it to the tune of about 95
plus percent you see that's what we
should have done we should do it now
just shut it all down everyone stays
inside waits for their mailbox money
well our terrible gdp numbers released
this week for the second quarter
are due entirely to unemployment and of
course
that's caused by the shutdowns consumer
confidence is in the toilet
kids will be stuck at home looking at
screens in much of america this fall
hurting them and their families but the
democrats just consider it all
necessary political collateral damage on
the way
to they hope defeating donald trump oh
and by the way
the eurozone released its numbers today
and they're in a
full-blown recession the worst on record
france's economy shrank by nearly 14
percent in the second quarter
spain fared even worse their gdp
contracted nearly 19 percent
that's double what we lost but democrats
consider all of this a success story
and finally today this took the kick
senate democrats left town rather than
agree to a short-term extension of
unemployment benefits proposed by
republicans
and even cnn couldn't spin the democrats
behavior
while there were some offers from the
white house to temporarily
extend this extra 600 a week benefit
that so many people are depending on the
democrats didn't agree to that
the fear is that if you let this go as a
standalone bill
you lose leverage in future negotiations
leverage did you hear that
leverage these are real
people's real lives at stake
so instead of acting in the nation's
best interest democrats are willing once
again to see
needless pain inflicted on american
citizens
because you see human suffering to them
is useful if it gets them closer to
their socialist utopia
of a massive increase in people
dependent on the government
and a massive increase in state control
over every
aspect of our lives every step of the
way
we see democrats choose chaos over
common sense
they're okay with trashing the country's
economy taxpayer property
and our history they're fine with
denigrating cabinet members as part of a
show for the cameras
and they're even okay with hurting
children by peddling false panic
about school reopenings and finally
they'll let you twist in the wind
instead of working with republicans
this entire year has been a
post-impeachment revenge quest for
democrats
and they only hate trump remember
because they hate the america that
elected him
they need that america to get so
demoralized
that they stop fighting for their own
lives and liberty
but they've made a very risky bet with
this course they're on
and they've gone all in but so must we
we owe that much to our children our
grandchildren and to those who came
before us so let's stop complaining and
start doing
register people to vote and educate
everyone who'll listen i promise
i'm going to do my part and that's the
angle